[Music]
from quick revealing shots to comic book
lore
there's plenty to dig into in the teaser
trailer for marvel's newest film
here are the small details you missed in
the eternals
teaser trailer while eager mcu fans
haven't gotten a full plot synopsis of
eternals yet
marvel has given some basic insight on
what the film
is about the eternals are a race of
immortal cosmic humanoids created by the
alien celestials who have secretly been
living on earth for centuries
but when an unexpected tragedy befalls
earth the eternals are pushed out of
hiding
and must band together to defeat the
deviants mankind's most ancient enemy
the song featured in the teaser trailer
1962's the end of the world
by skeeter davis gives us some further
insight into the calamity the eternals
will be facing
the end of the world encapsulates the
devastation felt after a breakup
unfortunately it seems the end of the
world in the eternals will be a bit more
literal
as suggested by marvel's brief synopsis
the arrival
of the deviants indicates a potential
world-ending event that only the
eternals can stop
near the beginning of the eternal's
teaser trailer a strange rectangular
aircraft spontaneously materializes in
front of a group of humans
living on the shore near an ocean the
eternals who are soon revealed to be
inside the ship
admire the planet with cersei talking
about it to icarus
as if she's bringing him to earth or
this time period of earth for the first
time
a spaceship descending upon a group of
unsuspecting humans
is standard affair for the mcu at this
point
what's the matter with you kids you've
never seen a spaceship before
still its appearance and the behavior of
its crew draw many questions about the
eternals place within the established
marvel canon
after all in the comics the eternals are
native to earth
having been created by the celestials
during their proto-humanity experiments
that also yielded
the deviants they do have colonies
elsewhere though
another likely option is that this ship
is a time machine of some kind
the eternals have traveled backward in
time to the age of primitive man before
the eternal fastos has even lent some of
their advanced technology to the tribal
humans
midway through the trailer there's a
shot of an internals handcuffing a
dagger
and a human's hand nervously reaching
out to take it
the dagger has obvious symbolic meaning
the shot
and ajax voiceover expressed the idea
that the eternals gave humans technology
to help them evolve
but after watching this moment in the
teaser fans may be asking whether the
dagger
is an important reference from the
comics the answer
as far as we can tell is that the dagger
itself isn't particularly significant
on its own the important part is that
it's imparting knowledge from the
eternals to humans
the moment is actually reminiscent of
the beginning of 2001
a space odyssey when the sudden
appearance of a mysterious monolith
inspires apes to start using tools
specifically
bones as weapons it's a similar idea of
alien intervention
inciting human evolution when makari is
reading her book at the 1 minute and 7
second mark in the teaser trailer
she's surrounded by all sorts of ancient
artifacts
one of these is a gold statue that reads
spqr
which historians will recognize as the
abbreviation
for senatus populous romanus
or the senate and people of rome spqr
represents the government of the roman
republic which is dated
from 509 bc to 27 bc
as we know from the film's teaser
trailer the eternals have been around
for quite some time
with cersei noting that they have never
interfered with the people of earth
until the threat of the deviants arrives
of course
while they might not have been
interfering the eternals definitely
have been looming in the background
gathering artifacts from different
civilizations and time periods
other objects inside the artifact room
include a chimera statue
a statue of a gold sphinx cat and a
medieval
knight's armor makari is also surrounded
by hundreds of other books and
mysterious objects
some of which include old paintings in
the comics makari has many adventures
in human history and even taught the
egyptians how to write
based on what we see of her in the
eternal's teaser trailer it looks like
she might have taken tokens from
different civilizations in the past
where she was present
the eternal's teaser trailer briefly but
effectively
sets up the romance between two of the
eternals cersei
and icarus the pair are the first
members of the eternals
shown in the footage as cersei is seen
commenting on earth's beauty to icarus
shortly after the group's ship arrives
on the planet from there
the eternals teaser trailer features
several moments between icarus and
cersei
marvel's kevin feige has previously said
that gemma chan's cersei
is the closest thing that eternals has
to a lead character
so her relationship with icarus will
likely play a major role in the film's
plot
in the comics although cersei and icarus
are both members of the eternals
they've never had a notable romance
together however
cersei has had a romantic relationship
with dane whitman
aka black knight in the comics kit
harrington
is playing him in eternals it's also
worth noting
that chan previously told vanity fair
italy that cersei would be involved in
two
love stories in the film so it's very
likely eternals will see a love triangle
take form between cersei icarus
and dane the eternals teaser trailer
offers interesting hints
about the titular group's powers
particularly the golden
intricately patterned energy threads
seen in multiple spots they're most
prominently on display
in a shot that shows cersei druid and
makari
levitating a few feet above the beach
while the golden energy connects the
trio
this might be a manifestation of one of
the eternal's main powers
the ability to wield cosmic energy
judging by druid's elevated hands and
the fact that the gold strands seem to
emanate from him
it seems that whatever is happening here
he's the guy taking the lead and
connecting himself to cersei
and makari since druid's comic book
counterpart has considerable telepathic
powers at his disposal
there might be some mind linking going
on it remains to be seen
just why this is happening though the
villains of eternals are the deviants
the mortal enemies of the eternals but
it's currently unknown who's playing
them or what they'll look like
marvel hasn't revealed that information
and the teaser trailer doesn't give fans
much more to go on
however there's a brief glimpse of
something that could be a deviant
plus a hint the kind of powers the
deviants have at the 1 minute 28 second
mark of the teaser trailer
kingo is seen in battle he slides under
what looks like some kind of cgi horse
creature and stabs it in the leg
which glows gold the footage then
quickly cuts to a group of villagers who
all have blank
glowing eyes they lift their guns in
unison suggesting
that they're being mind controlled the
scene is too quick to show anything
really needy
but there could be a deviant or several
deviants in it the villagers could be
deviants in disguise or might be humans
whom the deviants have possessed a
deviant could also be riding the horse
creature
or may have taken the form of the horse
creature itself since crow
the leader of the deviants is a
shapeshifter
at the 1 minute 30 second mark of the
eternal's teaser trailer
there's a volcano erupting over the
backdrop of the blue sky
while it's not exactly clear what the
context is for the exploding volcano
within the marvel comics canon
there have actually been eternal
storylines that prominently feature
volcanoes in flashbacks in 2012's hulk
volume 2
number 49 icarus bites red hulk on an
erupting volcano
and way back in 1960s tales of suspense
vol
1 issue 7 a character who would later be
reckoned
into makari is taking a vacation when
the molten man thing
emerges from an erupting volcano for the
time being though
there's no way to know for sure what the
erupting volcano means it could mark a
significant event in the film's plot or
simply be further proof of the deviances
destruction
and devastation of earth with all the
majestic world building and cool
costumes in the eternals teaser trailer
it's easy to forget that the movie also
features at least one prominent human
character
in fact the trailer nearly forgets him
too seeing as we only get a brief
glimpse of dane whitman
played by kit harington he stands beside
cersei
looking a little bit scruffy and wearing
decidedly normal
everyday clothes immediately after the
one and only close-up of the character
there's a shot of a group of people
looking worriedly as something very
strange is going on in the sky
of course it's almost certain that
you'll see plenty more of dane in the
movie
as previously mentioned in the comics
dane has a history with cersei
that will potentially translate to the
big screen more importantly
marvel comics fans know that dane
ultimately becomes a sword-wielding
superhero
called black knight and common sense
dictates that you don't cast a major
game of thrones alum
to play a sword-wielding character
unless he's meant to be a pretty big
part of the movie
but unfortunately we're as lost as he is
about what it all means you know nothing
jon snow at the 1 minute and 31 second
mark of the eternal's teaser trailer
viewers can see sprite on what appears
to be an airplane
singing karaoke for the truly eagle-eyed
viewers an
old-fashioned captain america shield can
be seen hanging on the wall next to the
door
and behind the bar this brief moment
also suggests that the plane the heroes
are riding on
belongs to kingo played by kumail
najiyani
the eternals member whose secret
identity is as a bollywood celebrity
having a k on the door could signify
that this is his plane which fits
perfectly with the character as he's
reportedly not exactly great at keeping
things on the dl
as for the captain america shield we can
only imagine
that kingo is a fan of the star-spangled
avenger
the eternals were always going to be a
tough nut to crack
cinematically speaking they're
compelling enough characters once you
dig in but on the surface
they're a pretty odd bunch that's part
of why marvel editor-in-chief joe cusada
tasked neil gaiman and john romita jr
with breathing
new more relatable life into the
characters back
in the mid-2000s the result was eternals
a seven-part mini-series that reworked
the mythology of jack kirby's race of
immortals
wiping enough of their memories to
warrant reintroductions and warm
welcoming exposition as with lots of
rebooted comics from the last few years
the story took the pre-built foundations
of the universe and constructed a more
screen-ready version of events for new
readers
and optimistically studio executives to
latch onto
from what we've seen in this first
teaser trailer the movie seems to take
influence from the comic book miniseries
the biggest hint comes from the ominous
shots of sprite
who spends the comic series on a reality
warping rage bender
after millennia spent trapped in the
body of a child
finally catch up with the little hell
racer sprites
crusade to reshape existence and
particularly their tendency to mess
with people's memories would go a long
way towards explaining why nobody in the
mcu
has noticed the eternals until now
as the trailer closes out at the 1
minute and 50 second mark
the eternals sit around a table enjoying
a meal so now that captain rogers and
iron man are both gone
who do you think's gonna lead the
avengers
i could lead them in the original
eternals comics icarus does serve as the
prime eternal
the leader of the earth eternals and
though he fights alongside the avengers
sometimes he doesn't serve as the
group's leader
like tony or capdo however a different
character involved with the eternals did
lead the avengers
kit harington's dane whitman whether or
not icarus or dane will eventually team
up with or even lead the avengers in any
future mcu films
is anyone's guess at this point either
way icarus and dane will both be able to
show off their leadership skills in
eternals when the film
hits theaters on november 5th check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book heroes and villains
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one